yeah i know you have this
um interesting challenge coming up and
i'm curious what you're going to do to
reset
in the hours it that the frequency of
running is
um every four hours it's not going to
allow you to get any more than
a couple hours sleep in between flowers
so we should we should tell the people
i'd be curious to get your thoughts and
advice on it i'm uh
on march 5th running 48 miles with
mr david goggins so four miles every
four hours and people should join us
he's uh
that madman is going to be live on
instagram
starting at 8 p.m pacific on march
5th so you're going to join him in
person in person
undisclosed location undisclosed
location and i was i was trying to
clarify like okay so we're gonna
like there'll be like friendly people
around or something no it's just me and
him friendly people i don't know
like i just feel it's very difficult to
be
with david alone in the room i imagine
his
i mean i've done some work with david
his energy is infectious yeah
that's an intense schedule um and the
the periodicity of those four hour every
four hours four miles
means that there's no chance of catching
an extended block of sleep
so it's about three hours that you have
non-exercising every time
and of course it takes time to try to
fall asleep and there's an intensity to
the whole thing
i mean it's probably impossible to get
anything more
than uh two hours of sleep if you wanted
to so the optimal thing is probably
from the sound of it i'd be curious to
see what you think
but like it's getting a few 90-minute
naps okay well i thought about this a
bit
before we met up today so i think there
are two general approaches that could
work neither one necessarily better than
the other
one would be just to hammer through the
whole thing
just to get your level of alertness and
adrenaline
ramped up so that you don't expect
yourself to sleep
there are certain advantages there one
is a subjective kind of emotional
advantage
which is if you can't sleep you're not
gonna be stressed about that yes
and if you do fall asleep it's a bonus
provided you wake up and you don't look
up and you realize david's been out
running for half an hour and you're
behind right
but chances are that's not the way it'll
go you set an alarm so that's one
approach
yeah and and i grabbed that from you
know a
couple friends who were um who are in
the seal teams and they'll say that you
know during buds there's this
infamous hell week and there's this five
hour five days excuse me definitely five
days
of no sleep although there is a
component where they offer a nap at one
particular point
and a lot of people will say that it's
worse to go down for that
nap and then be woken up 20 minutes
later than to just stay up
so so that's one option let's call it
the um full blitz hammer through
option and if you happen to fall asleep
you do bonus yeah it's a bonus
the other one would be to really anchor
in these ultradian cycles so coming back
from a run
you unless you're thoroughly exhausted
you're probably going to have a few
minutes where you're
going to want to stay awake it's going
to be hard to just immediately fall
asleep and
getting as much sleep as you can in the
intervening periods
provided you guys aren't posting
constantly or doing something else you
also
there's a question whether or not you
want to nourish whether or not you want
to eat or not in that time
anytime we put food in our gut i don't
care if it's meat
or oatmeal or
broccoli or cardboard you're drawing
blood into the gut
and so you are going to divert some
energy towards digestion and it's going
to make you sleepy there's a reason why
the rest and digest the parasympathetic
nervous system is called that
so you could decide that you were only
going to sleep in certain
in between certain blocks that would be
another way to think about this
that because i did this last year
uh i ran very slow some of it was
walking i was listening audiobooks and
one of the biggest mistakes i did is to
overeat during that time right it was uh
made the experience very unpleasant so i
have been considering basically eating
almost nothing
throughout the day being fasted will
increase alertness because
high levels of epinephrine in your
system from fasting you just think about
fasting or being thirsty
before you get exhausted people always
think if i don't eat i'm going to be
tired
no that the energy that you derive from
food is going to be
uh used from glycogen and after a long
storage and conversion process so
the food that you eat is going to
consume energy to digest
and so a lot of people feel better
fasted and
presumably throughout history people
have fasted for long periods of time and
had to stay up for two or three days and
you know god forbid if a family member
is sick you can stay awake in the
hospital
without any trouble so that alertness
system and it's you know it's all mental
um actually and then there's a third
so you could try and sleep or or take
care in between yes
yeah and then there's a third approach
uh-oh yeah but
i didn't come up with it but david did
so
i actually texted him earlier because i
had a feeling that
i heard that you were going to do this
challenge so
i asked david um
so these are david goggins words not
mine
okay one okay
being organized is super important two
you want to waste as little
time as possible three you need to eat
sleep and rehab in as little time as
possible so you can sleep as much as
possible
oh interesting by the way this is the
first time i'm reading this yeah
um four meal prep and gear prep etc are
very important
that's um that's consistent with
everything i know about military they
they don't
they don't leave too much to chance five
again these are david's words all that
said he's [ __ ] on most all that
because he'll be interviewing me before
or after i will also be interviewing him
oh [ __ ] five long story short the only
thing that might help is a very special
pill
this is interesting they're called s-i-u
pills
hard to get but i believe you can get
them siu stands for suck it up
tell him to grab his balls he will find
those pills there
that's number six all right and then the
last one stay hard brother
say hi brother amen i
you know that was one of the other
things that i think makes this
challenging is that
it'll be doing a podcast throughout so
first of all i'll do a long one before
and after but also
i'll have to come up with things to talk
to him about
so like it's a different thing to do
something
privately and then publicly i know it
doesn't
seem that way but like one of the
hardest
the hardest thing i had to do last time
was to turn on the camera and talk to
the camera
because i uh last time i did it i
recorded um
every single time i did a leg i recorded
something i'm grateful for
it's just kind of unrelated i'm not a
fan of like talking about like how i'm
feeling
or how long is going i want to do
something totally unrelated to the run
and with the run as the background you
know so sort of something i'm grateful
for
just any kind of uh interesting
discussion gratitude
i mean i hate the word hack like oh it's
a dopamine hack or it's a serotonin i i
don't like the word hack because
hey it's disrespectful to hackers who do
a real thing yeah and
b a hack implies that it's some sort of
trick that you're
you're you're kind of gaming the system
you know what
what works is mechanism right biological
mechanisms
were designed to work and they were
selected for
to work under variable conditions and as
you know and i know and
we have great appreciation for the fact
that the nervous system was designed to
be an adaptive machine
so that you don't have to sleep eight
hours every night
you can do this thing and things like
gratitude allow you to tap into chemical
resources
and that's not a hack the fact that
being grateful for something external to
the event
happens to release serotonin and have a
certain soothing effect or
dopamine and give you more epinephrine
and let you go further
that's not a hack that's actually what
allowed the
human machine to evolve to the point
that it is now
every time you know an inventor
eventually
created something that worked and felt
great about it you can imagine that the
the first you know air flight felt
pretty awesome
and motivated those people to go on and
do more they they didn't just go ah you
know yawn and go have a beer
so being able to access the genuine in
internal states of gratitude and reward
works
you can't trick the system you can't
pretend that you're grateful for
something but if you can identify or
attach yourself to some larger
goal or something that's deeply
gratifying to you or
place it in service to a relative that
passed away that you
care a lot about that's not a hack
that's accessing the deepest components
of your nervous system
and um to steal your kind of lingo
there's real beauty there
right yeah but for an introvert like
myself
and i think david i don't know if he's
an introvert but like
he's not despite the fact that he has
written a great book
and he communicates he puts himself out
there he's not really
a fan of communication he's not i don't
know
if he's energized by speaking his mind
i don't know him well enough to know i
mean we've done a little bit of work
together and
um you know we're in communication now
and again he's obviously super
impressive
um i don't know it seems that he's a pr
it seems like he's a pretty private guy
yeah you know so i don't have access to
that so for me
i'll just speak to myself and i think
david is the same but i'll speak to
myself that it was a hugely draining
thing
not to experience the gratitude
experiencing the gratitude just like
you're saying
is really energizing and it's
it's a powerful thing it's a it's a it
can
lift up your mood but to turn on the
camera and have to
use words which is very difficult to do
to explain
like what you're feeling and do it in
the way that you know a bunch of people
will be watching
is really draining and one of the things
i'm concerned about
that in this whole process how do
i keep my mind sharp while also
keeping the perform the physical
performance shop and that's a little bit
scary because
talking to david like actual
intellectually sharp
like thinking being charismatic and
as much as i can be and like being still
maintaining a sense of humor too because
i can be i become
with sleep deprivation with exhaustion
you start being
the russian bear comes out you start
being such a d
like you i become a david goggins
essentially like
oh it makes you irritable
you